[Música]
el ejército ruso bombardeo intensamente
kiev sin embargo aún no ha logrado tomar
el control en medio de una nueva jornada
fallida de diálogo entre las partes en
belarús entretanto la onu corroboró la
muerte de 691 civiles desde el inicio de
la invasión rusa
más de 3 millones de refugiados han
tenido que salir de ucrania tras 20 días
de ofensiva rusa sobre el país según
datos de la organización internacional
para las migraciones acnur por su parte
estima que el 90% de ellos son mujeres y
niños que han huido en su mayoría a la
vecina polonia
murió otro periodista que informaba
sobre la guerra en ucrania se trata del
camarógrafo de foxnews y ersa zewski
quien fue alcanzado por varios disparos
mientras circulaba en un vehículo con él
son ya cuatro los periodistas fallecidos
en ucrania
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 ser rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos el ejército ruso
bombardeo intensamente quiere el martes
sin embargo no ha logrado tomar el
control sobre la capital ucraniana rusa
atacó al menos tres edificios
residenciales la entrada de una estación
de tren donde miles de personas han
buscado refugio y un supermercado
aledaño entretanto la organización de
naciones unidas- corroboró la muerte de
691 civiles en medio de la invasión rusa
que inició el 24 de febrero 48 de ellas
serían menores de edad sin embargo la
onu advirtió que las cifras reales de
heridos y fallecidos podrían ser
considerablemente superiores mientras
tanto en una muestra de unión tres
líderes europeos visitaron kiev
un muro de países contra rusia los
primeros ministros de polonia república
checa y eslovenia miembros de la otan
llegaron hasta la sitiada que para
mostrarle su apoyo al presidente
ucraniano y aunque volodymyr selenski
aceptó que su país no entrara en la
alianza trasatlántica insistió a las
naciones que lo integran que le envíen
asistencia militar para defenderse de la
invasión de rusia
si no podemos entrar por las puertas
abiertas tenemos que cooperar con las
plataformas y los sindicatos que nos
permitan hacerlo nos ayudarán a
protegernos por ejemplo con sus
plataformas y nos gustaría también tener
garantías individuales
la mayoría de los países que rodean
ucrania son miembros de la otan y han
formado un muro de contención a
excepción de belarús quien al principio
del conflicto facilitó en su territorio
la llegada de tropas rusas y el
lanzamiento de misiles contra ucrania y
hungría país que a pesar de ser miembro
de la alianza le compra petróleo y gas a
moscú y cuyo primer ministro viktor
orbán tiene buenas relaciones con el
ruso vladimir putin desde hace más de 10
años precisamente este martes en un acto
de campaña para las parlamentarias del
próximo 3 de abril el primer ministro
húngaro fijó una postura de no
intervención en el conflicto nuestro
interés es que no nos convirtamos en
víctimas de la guerra de otra persona de
esta guerra no tenemos nada que ganar
sino todo que perder debemos permanecer
al margen de esta guerra el partido de
derecha de viktor orbán se enfrentará
por primera vez desde 2010 al frente
unido conformado por 6 partidos de
oposición en los comicios se elegirán
199 miembros de la asamblea nacional que
deben elegir al primer ministro de
hungría para el periodo 2022 2026
en 20 días de invasión más de 3 millones
de refugiados han salido de ucrania
huyendo de los constantes ataques de las
fuerzas rusas el 90% de los exiliados
son mujeres y niños cada minuto 55 mil
menores salen de ucrania hacia terceros
países según unicef un drama humanitario
que se podría agravar si el conflicto
continúa marina sardiña con los detalles
más de 3 millones de refugiados
ucranianos el éxodo más masivo y que a
mayor velocidad aumenta desde la segunda
guerra mundial el drama de 19 días de
invasión rusa reflejado en los rostros
de los más pequeños al menos 14 millones
de niños cada minuto 55 menores huyen
del país voy a tomar desde que comenzó
la guerra el 24 de febrero cada segundo
un niño se ha convertido en refugiados
fuera de ucrania rise kent acnur informó
que cerca del 90% del éxodo está formado
por mujeres y niños también miles de
ancianos han logrado huir por tanto poco
más de lo opuesto porque los ataques
rusos no dan tregua y se ensañan cada
vez más contra objetivos civiles
en heart cop da mucho miedo todo está
bombardeado la ciudad está destruida no
hay edificios ni casas el centro de la
ciudad ha sido destruido han atacado
barrios residenciales todo ha
desaparecido mucha gente se está
marchando ahí sólo queda una cuarta
parte de la población
más de 18 millones de personas se han
dirigido a polonia el principal receptor
de refugiados ucranianos miles más han
cruzado las fronteras con hungría
rumanía o moldavia también se estima que
hay 19 millones de desplazados internos
al otro lado de las fronteras
voluntarios y ong se dan refugio y
alimentos como estos taxistas españoles
que se trasladaron hasta polonia para
ofrecer sus servicios a los ucranianos
la gente está volcada hemos tenido
muchísima ayuda muchísimo
muchísimos colaboradores a nivel
particular
yo me queda un poco vamos directamente
desbordado porque porque conocí dos
amigos cuando se han enterado incluso
algo clientes en el taxi que se lo
contaba se han volcado con él con el
tema el pasado 3 de marzo el bloque
europeo acordó ofrecer protección
temporal en la refugio ucranianos
mientras acnur prevé que de continuar el
conflicto el éxodo podría superar las 4
millones de personas
y murió otro periodista que informaba
sobre la guerra en ucrania foxnews
aseguró que su camarógrafo pierre cassez
quien fue asesinado después de que el
vehículo en el que viajaba fuera
alcanzado por varios disparos otra
periodista en el terreno también
falleció estos decesos se suman a los
del comunicador ver en reno o cineasta y
periodista estadounidense que falleció
en la ciudad de irving cerca de kiev
si quieres a jet ski de 55 años ser un
veterano en zonas de guerra cubrió
varios conflictos en irak afganistán y
siria
trabajaba en ucrania desde febrero la
productor ucraniana del equipo de fox
saia cubs innova murió en el mismo
incidente su colega de foxnews benjamin
jal también está en el hospital resultó
herido después de que fueran atacados
cerca de kiev
la muerte de esas eps que se suma la de
brand y reynolds cineasta y periodista
estadounidense que trabajaba para el new
york times' muerto por disparos de las
fuerzas rusas de la ciudad del ping
cerca de la capital ucraniana el pasado
fin de semana reporteros sin fronteras
que presta apoyo a periodistas y medios
de comunicación afirma que la prensa es
especialmente vulnerable en este
conflicto
de liberty
los periodistas son objetivos de ataques
deliberados por parte de algunas tropas
rusas como se ha demostrado en
diferentes ocasiones occasions against
honor o rabia como por ejemplo contra un
equipo de al arabiya news uno de skynews
un equipo danés y un periodista suizo
así que fue un milagro que ningún
periodista internacional fuera asesinado
antes del sábado no internaciones what
else before sad de según reporteros sin
fronteras el mayor riesgo lo corren los
numerosos periodistas ucranianos que no
tienen formación en reportajes de guerra
y el equipo para trabajar y que intentan
ayudar directamente
craig reporteros sin fronteras creó e
inauguró oficialmente el sábado pasado
en la ciudad de linfen tour de france
football centre un centro de libertad de
prensa para entregar chalecos antibalas
cascos y herramientas de seguridad a los
periodistas safety
tools para que podamos empezar a
formarlos en los próximos días
singh
según las autoridades ucranianas dos
periodistas ucranianos han muerto desde
el inicio de la invasión rusa el 24 de
febrero uno de ellos yevgueni sakun
murió en el ataque a la torre de
televisión de kiev y el otro víctor
dudar murió en la ciudad portuaria de
mykolaiv al sur del país marina opciã
nico va la periodista del canal uno ruso
que apareció en directo con mensajes en
contra de la guerra fue declarada
culpable de violar las leyes de protesta
en lo que el kremlin tildó de un acto de
vandalismo la periodista fue multada con
el equivalente a 280 dólares estas
fueron sus palabras al salir del
tribunal
quiero agradecer a todos por su apoyo a
mis amigos y colegas fueron días
difíciles de mi vida porque pasé dos
días sin dormir el interrogatorio duró
más de 14 horas no me permitieron
contactar a mis familiares me
proporcionaron cualquier ayuda jurídica
estaba en una situación muy difícil el
comité internacional de la cruz roja y
otros socios afiliados enviaron un
convoy de camiones con doscientas
toneladas de ayuda humanitaria a la
ciudad ucraniana de binish ya los 11
camiones entregaron material que se
dispersara por toda ucrania entre la
ayuda transportada se encontraban
botiquines médicos para heridos de
guerra paquetes de ayuda y suministros
de agua y saneamiento
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
con nosotros en france 24 y en france 24
punto com
[Música]